hey this is presh talker
this puzzle has been shared with the
claim that only a genius could solve it
it has gone viral on facebook and the
internet
generating millions of views as people
have debated what the correct answer
should be
in this video i'm going to present what
many people believe to be the correct
answer
can you figure it out
give it a try before watching the rest
of the video
so most people believe the correct
answer is 36.
this is found by taking the product of
the sum of the digits in each
multiplication
when multiplying two numbers a a and a a
you obtain the answer by taking the sum
of the digits in each multiplication and
then multiplying that together
for example to do eleven times eleven we
would take the quantity one plus one and
multiply it by the quantity one plus one
this equals two times two
which gets to four as given in the
puzzle
similarly
22 times 22
the answer can be found by taking two
plus 2 times the quantity 2 plus 2.
this equals 4 times 4
which equals 16 as given in the puzzle
this would mean 33 times 33 would equal
3 plus 3 times the quantity 3 plus 3.
this equals 6 times 6 which is 36.
so most people believe this is the
correct answer
however there are people who think the
answer should be 18.
they believe the procedure to get the
answer is to take the sum of the digits
in the product of the regular
multiplication
for example
eleven times eleven is equal to a
hundred and twenty-one
the answer can be obtained by taking one
plus two plus one which is four
similarly 22 times 22 is equal to 484
the answer can be found by taking the
sum of the digits in the product which
is 4 plus 8 plus 4 which is 16.
this would mean 33 times 33 is equal to
1089
the answer can be found by taking the
sum of the digits 1 0 8 and 9 which gets
to the answer of 18.
so we have two different answers we have
36 and 18 and both methods seem valid
so is there any way to reconcile these
two different approaches to the problem
in fact there is a way to justify the
answer of 36 under the sum of the digits
in the product
let's see how that works
so we start out with eleven times eleven
we can expand each term in the
multiplication
to write this as ten plus one times ten
plus one
if we expand out this product we get one
times a hundred plus two times ten
plus one times one
this gets us to the familiar answer of a
hundred and twenty-one and if we take
the sum of the digits we get one plus
two plus one which is four
there's an alternate way that we can
visualize what's going on here
we could do this by multiplying by lines
let's do eleven times eleven for the
first number 11 we'll draw one line and
then we'll leave some space and we'll
draw another line
for the other 11 we'll draw lines in the
other direction
leaving spaces between the two ones
we can now get to the answer by counting
the number of vertically aligned
intersections
on the far right we have one
intersection
this will be one
in the center we have two intersections
this will be two
finally on the far left we have one
intersection which makes for one
so we can
copy these numbers and we get to our
familiar answer of 121.
now we can add up the digits in the
answer to get one plus two plus one
which equals four
so there's another interpretation that
we've just shown is valid when we're
summing up the digits of the product
what we're really doing is we're
counting the number of dots in this
diagram
so here we have exactly four dots in our
diagram and that corresponds to adding
up one plus two plus one
so let's continue this pattern
so we'll start out algebraically with
twenty two times twenty two
we can rewrite this as twenty plus two
times twenty plus two
we can expand this out to get four times
a hundred plus eight times ten plus four
times one
this is equal to our answer of 484
and the sum of the digits is equal to
16.
so now let's look at the same problem
visually
we'll do 22 times 22 by multiplying by
lines
so for the first 22 we draw two lines
for the 20 we'll leave some space and
draw two lines for the two
for the other number we do the same
thing but draw lines in the other
direction
we'll now get to the answer by counting
the number of intersections that are
vertically aligned
so we'll start with the group of
intersections on the far right
there are four intersections here
in the center
we have one group of four and another
group of four
this makes for a total of eight
intersections
on the far left we have four
intersections
so copying these numbers we get to our
familiar answer of
484 and if we add up the digits in our
answer 4 plus 8 plus 4 we get 16
which once again
is the number of dots in our diagram
so now let's apply the procedure to 33
times 33.
we'll first consider an algebraic
procedure
we have 30 plus 3 times 30 plus 3.
we'll expand this out we get 9 times 100
plus eighteen times ten plus nine times
one
so we could write our answer as nine
hundreds eighteen tens and nine ones
and if we were to add up the digits in
this product we would get 9 plus 18 plus
9 which is 36
so this is not how we would typically
write this answer if you put 33 times 33
in a calculator you would not get 9 18
and 9. although this is a valid
representation of 33 times 13 33.
what we do is in the decimal system we
never have any value be more than 9 in
our placeholders
so the problem is this eighteen times
ten
we need to split that up into ten times
ten plus eight times ten
now ten times ten is equal to a hundred
so that adds one more into our hundreds
place
so we have ten hundreds plus eight tens
and then nine ones
now ten hundreds is also equal to one
thousand
so our final answer is one times a
thousand plus zero hundreds plus eight
tens plus nine ones
so this is the more familiar way that we
write out thirty three times thirty
three which is one thousand eighty nine
but if we were to ignore this carryover
rule you could see this representation
is a valid way to represent 33 times 33
and if we did add up the sum of the
digits in this product we would get to
the answer of 36.
one more way to illustrate this is by
doing the visual multiplication
so we'll draw three lines for the 30
we'll leave some space and draw three
more lines for the units three
for the other number we draw the lines
in the other direction again leaving
some space between the tens and the ones
values
so on the far right we count the number
of intersections
we have nine intersections here
in the center we have two groups of nine
this makes for a total of 18
intersections and on the far left we
have nine intersections
so we have our answer of nine eighteen
nine
and we know this represents
nine times a hundred plus eighteen times
ten plus nine times one
we could go ahead and do the carryover
process and we would get to the answer
of 1089
however
if we just want to count the number of
dots in this diagram we would get to the
answer that there are 9 plus 18 plus 9
which is 36 dots in this diagram so that
could be a valid way of counting the sum
of the digits in the product if we don't
take carryover and we just count the
number of dots in each column
so what this means is we'll go over our
procedure so if we count the sum of the
digits in the product
for 11 times 11 and 22 times 22 we do
get 4 and 16 as in the puzzle
and finally we then need to figure out
what 33 times 33 is
we could validly write this as 9 18 and
9 as long as we don't have any carry
over and we understand where the
placeholders represent
so this would get us to an answer of 36
and this would exactly match the
procedure that we use to get the product
of the sum of the digits if you go
through a time a plus a times a plus a
that's exactly what we're doing when
we're doing the sum of the digits in the
product with no carryover and it's the
same procedure that we're using to count
the number of the dots in our diagram
for visual multiplication
so it would seem that 36 is the answer
to this puzzle
did you get to 36
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description